[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y Estos son
nuestros titulares
en Brasil se cumplieron cinco años del
asesinato de Mariel y Franco defensora
de los Derechos Humanos el presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva nombró a la
hermana de la fallecida concejala de Río
de Janeiro como ministra de igualdad
racial y creó un grupo de investigación
sobre el crimen lo que da Esperanza Pese
a que el homicidio no sea resuelto en un
lustro el equipo de France 24 en Río de
Janeiro nos cuenta más
y un paro minero que según el gobierno
de Gustavo Petro es instigado por la
banda criminal clan del Golfo genera
caos en el noroeste de Colombia más de
250.000 personas se enfrentan escasez de
alimentos y agua potable debido a los
bloqueos que han derivado en acciones
violentas tenemos informe de los
reporteros de France 24 en terreno y
cada año mueren entre 8.000 y 14.000
personas en Ciudad de México por causas
ligadas a la contaminación por lo que el
gobierno local tomó medidas para buscar
fuentes de energía limpia los
periodistas de France 24 en México nos
traen la historia
y vamos de inmediato a Brasil porque se
cumplieron cinco años del asesinato de
la concejala de Río de Janeiro María Eli
Franco defensora de los derechos humanos
simpatizantes y familiares le rindieron
homenaje Como cada año y la corresponsal
de France 24 habló con ellos y nos envió
el siguiente informe
desde aquel fatídico 14 de marzo de 2018
cada año millares de personas salen a la
calle para exigir la verdad sobre el
asesinato de la concejala María Eli
Franco pues que no pusieron un país como
Brasil en un país como Brasil que tiene
el mayor número de personas negras fuera
de África que tiene mucho mestizaje toda
la historia de este país fue construida
por la población negra no es posible que
maten a una concejal mujer y negra de la
forma en que fue asesinada y que nos
conformemos con eso
ni la sociedad civil ni los familiares
han dejado de pedir una acción enérgica
al Estado tras la llegada al poder del
presidente Lula la policía federal ha
abierto una nueva línea de investigación
la madre de María Elite no se resigna
cada día que pasa nuestro dolor aumenta
no conseguimos hacer el luto este luto
del que precisamos después de cinco años
las autoridades de Río de Janeiro tienen
que dar estas respuestas no solo para mí
como madre sino también para los
electores de Mariel para la familia
también y para el Brasil que clama por
la justicia social porque eso es lo que
Mariel hacía Daniel y Franco hermana de
la víctima es ahora ministra de igualdad
racial su presencia en El Ejecutivo
puede acelerar un desenlace creo que
tenemos que tener esperanzas yo nunca la
perdí aprendí con mi madre y con mi
familia a tener fe Siempre no es una
casualidad que hayamos conseguido
mantener este legado en los últimos
cinco años pero no podemos olvidar el
peso y la responsabilidad de dar una
respuesta a la democracia de Brasil
porque es una mujer asesinada con cinco
tiros en la cabeza cuando era concejala
es inadmisible que todavía no sepamos
quién ordenó la muerte de Mariel Y por
qué artistas de la María de la Favela
donde creció María Eli tocaron durante
un festival reivindicativo y al mismo
tiempo emotivo la familia Espera que
pronto se celebra el juicio contra los
dos autores materiales del crimen de
momento Son los únicos sospechosos y
están presos preventivamente desde 2019
y en Colombia desde inicios de marzo
mineros artesanales Del Noroeste del
país iniciaron una protesta contra las
operaciones del ejército y de la policía
que en un intento de controlar la
minería ilegal de oro destruyeron los
equipos utilizados en la explotación
según el gobierno encabezado por Gustavo
Petro detrás de esa movilización está el
grupo narcotraficante conocido como el
clan del Golfo que obtiene dinero a
través de la explotación ilegal de
minerales el informe es de los enviados
especiales de France 24
solo se permite el paso a las
ambulancias en esta barricada
improvisada a la entrada de Puerto
libertador en la región de Córdoba los
mineros artesanales desafían al gobierno
llegan a la mina está a nosotros nos
queman las máquinas no queman los
motores arrestan barequeros Entonces ya
uno le tiene más miedo a la jueza
pública que a cualquier persona Desde
hace dos semanas la movilización de los
mineros sacude las regiones auríferas
del noroeste de Colombia la razón una
intensificación de los operativos
militares contra la minería ilegal el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro ha declarado
la guerra a la extracción salvaje de oro
a gran escala es acusada de causar
graves daños ambientales y de alimentar
las finanzas de los grupos armados
decenas de miles de familias viven de la
búsqueda de oro en Colombia en la mina
el Alacrán las técnicas son ancestrales
y hemos trabajado Pues en Santa Paz ha
habido muchos grupos armados pero
nosotros pues como no nos metemos con
nadie no no tenemos problema nunca han
obtenido una licencia de explotación el
título minero fue otorgado a una empresa
canadiense ahora llegó la empresa
y quiere pues que desocupemos hace dos
años las autoridades intentaron
desalojarlos desde entonces la comunidad
tiene ser atacada en cualquier momento
el botón de pánico cuando algo sucede
para convocar la comunidad en la plaza
lo que hacemos Es unir estos dos
cablecitos
[Aplausos]
las razones del paro son complejas y
algunos bloqueos son más violentos que
otros durante varios días pueblos
enteros fueron paralizados lo que sembró
el miedo y la ira entre parte de la
población
que van a atravesar los carros y
entonces si no puede pasar uno ya
quieren quemar una mula quieren quemar
un carro no nos podemos permitir
queman carro y hay plomo mis amigos
según las autoridades el paro minero
estaría orquestado por el clan del Golfo
un grupo armado financiado por la
minería ilegal y que se encuentra en un
acercamiento de paz con el gobierno si
el plan del Golfo está detrás del paro
como muchos de los indicios así lo
demuestran hay que decirlo no tiene
voluntad de paz Sí en su cabeza lo que
tiene es defender a un transa las
economías ilegales la minería o el
narcotráfico los impopulares bloqueos se
han levantado pero el diálogo entre
mineros y gobierno está suspendido en
los últimos días las autoridades han
destruido nuevas dragas ilegales la
atención sigue viva y en Perú El
Congreso sigue bloqueando el adelanto de
las elecciones presidenciales esta
semana por quinta vez los congresistas
rechazaron cambiar el cronograma
electoral para realizar los comicios en
diciembre y fijar el traspaso del poder
a abril de 2024 una de las peticiones de
los manifestantes que desde hace más de
tres meses salen a las calles en contra
de Dina boluarte Alba Santana nos
explica por qué
es un síntoma más de la profunda crisis
política que atraviesa Perú el bloqueo
del adelanto de elecciones en el
congreso una iniciativa que el poder
legislativo ya ha rechazado cinco veces
pero por qué la cámara lo está
bloqueando y porque es tan importante
para la ciudadanía con la destitución
del expresidente Pedro castillo y el
nombramiento de Dina boluarte a
principios de diciembre su mandato está
estipulado hasta 2026 pero muchos piden
el adelanto de los comicios por una
razón boluarte no fue elegida
democráticamente señoras y señores
congresistas tienen que entender su
responsabilidad histórica
el día de mañana
tiene la oportunidad de ganarse la
confianza del país
atendiendo esta demanda tan esperada por
el pueblo peruano de hecho el adelanto
de las elecciones a finales de este año
es una de las principales demandas de
las manifestaciones compartida entre el
87% de los ciudadanos según el instituto
de estudios peruanos que quieren elegir
en las urnas a su próximo mandatario o
mandatario es el mayor responsable del
caos que viva el Perú El Congreso tiene
su mano la solución y no quieren no
quieren este perder su privilegios si
quieren entornillarse en el poder la
comisión de la constitución del Congreso
está intentando responder a esta demanda
en la cámara y propone elecciones para
el segundo domingo de diciembre y el fin
del mandato de boluarte para el 30 de
abril de 2024 Pero hay un sector
particularmente reacio al adelanto los
congresistas de la derecha peruana que
aseguran que hay cosas más importantes
por por las que preocuparse Porque
necesitamos la paz cuanto antes porque
eso es lo primero que debemos de poner
delante y después podremos discutir
otras cosas no obstante la ciudadanía
los tacha de querer perpetuarse en sus
cargos ya que no quieren ceder a pesar
de la crisis social en la que está
sumida el país y al nivel de
desaprobación del Congreso que en
febrero alcanzó el 90%
y nos vamos a Ciudad de México que es
considerada una de las más contaminadas
del mundo debido a que a la vez es una
de las más pobladas del planeta por lo
que concentra además grandes industrias
cada año entre 8000 y 14.000 personas
mueren de manera prematura debido al
alto nivel de ozono y de partículas
finas que generan enfermedades
respiratorias y cardiovasculares el
gobierno local decidió actuar y busca
fuentes de energía limpia con la gran
ventaja que le otorga el tener más de
3.000 horas de sol al año el informe
desde el equipo de France 24 en México
una ciudad dentro de una ciudad que se
extiende 327 hectáreas 95 mil personas
trabajan aquí cada día es la Central de
Abasto de Ciudad de México el mercado de
alimentos más grande que surte a los
habitantes de la capital y parte del
país de más de 126 millones de
habitantes un lugar enorme en camino a
la conversión ecológica gracias a sus
paneles solares en la Ciudad de México
no tiene ya posibilidades de instalar
otras fuentes de generación como son las
convencionales refinerías o plantas
generadoras a base de hidrocarburos
entonces la única forma que tenemos es
para generar la energía solar y esta
planta es la muestra de que es posible
hacerlo en las grandes ciudades en total
esta planta solar debería producir 18
megavatios al año suficiente para suplir
las necesidades energéticas de 300.000
hogares prueba la finalización del
proyecto en junio los beneficios
económicos de la primera fase ya son
visibles la primera fase que tenemos de
las celdas solares va a implicar un
ahorro de tres y medio millones de pesos
en el consumo de luz de la Central de
Abasto en las áreas comunes también
posteriormente también ese consumo se va
a generar ese ahorro se va a generar en
áreas como el metro el sistema eléctrico
de la Ciudad de México e incluso también
se espera que para los participantes de
la Central de Abasto
en la central de abastos de la Ciudad de
México se venden aproximadamente 45 mil
toneladas de alimentos cada día y así
mismo se producen desechos
principalmente de aceites muy utilizados
en la cocina mexicana en su restaurante
Olivia Cisneros tira 20 litros de aceite
cada mes
anteriormente Esto no se usaba Entonces
se desechaba en las coladeras y nos
perjudicaba cuando llovía pues se
taponeaban las coladeras entonces pues
Excelente
servicio que están haciendo con el
aceite quemado que ya no utilizamos esto
una vez al mes el personal del mercado
recoge estos residuos de toda la ciudad
y los trasladan a esta planta inaugurada
en 2020 aquí se transforman cada mes
cinco mil litros de aceite en biodiesel
para su director la planta podría
producir mucho más la planta puede
producir 40.000 litros mensuales de
bioaditivo El problema es el acopio de
la materia prima porque es complicado
bueno porque la Ciudad de México es una
ciudad muy grande y los pequeños
generadores que se suman a los programas
de donación están muy atomizados están
muy dispersos en la Ciudad de México
hoy el biodiesel producido por esta
planta representa el 20% del combustible
que utilizan estos autobuses de la
Ciudad de México
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Jennifer Guevara
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web France 24.com
[Música]